اجتمع الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اليوم في
العاصمه البولنديه وارسو بقاده الدول
الاعضاء في حلف النيتو بشرق اوروبا واشار
بايدن خلال القمه الى ضروره زياده
المساعدات لاوكرانيا للدفاع عن سيادتها
ومن جهته قال الامين العام
ان الحلفه لن يسمح لروسيا بالانتصار
وسيدافع عن كل شبر من اراضي الدول الاعضاء
واضاف ان الرئيس الروسي بوتين ليس مستعدا
للسلم وان على النيتو تعزيز دعمه
لاوكرانيا لتحقيق نصرها
التزام الولايات المتحده بالنيتو واضح
تماما الماده الخامسه هي التزام مقدس
تعهدت به الولايات المتحده سندافع عن كل
شبر من النيتو هذه لحظه مهمه اتطلع فيها
الى المناقشات والخطوات التاليه التي يمكن
ان نتخذها معا للحفاظ على تحالفنا قويا
ولردع العدوان بشكل اكبر وما هو على المحك
بمعنى الكلمه ليس اوكرانيا فقط انها
الحريه